sophia richie and scott disick heat
things up in mexico there's never a dull
moment the rumored lovebirds are
currently enjoying a vacation in Punta
Mita Mexico and haven't been shy about
packing on the PDA in - on Monday the
two were photographed sneaking a steamy
kiss while they soaked up the Sun on a
jet ski later that day the 19 year old
daughter of Lionel Richie posted this
photo with her leg wrapped around the
keeping up with a Kardashian star to her
Instagram stories she captioned the shot
quote taco night earlier in the day the
34 year old also shared this snuggled up
pic on his own Instagram yep that's
Richie sitting on his lap planting a big
old kiss on his cheek and if that
weren't enough the teen also shared this
snapshot of them hugging it out on the
beach the two first sparked romance
rumours in May after they were spotted
cuddling on a yacht during the Cannes
Film Festival at the time Richie who was
previously linked to Justin Bieber
tweeted that the two were quote just
homies but in September while
vacationing in Miami they seemingly
confirmed the relationship locking lips
while enjoying a congratulations cake
[Music]